in recent days demonstrators have taken
to the streets across China to voice
frustration with their government's
strict zero coveted policy these
protests have become one of the greatest
public shows of defiance against the
Chinese Communist party in decades so
what exactly is zero covet and why is
Chinese leadership insisting on it zero
covid or dynamic zero copied centers
around eradicating the virus completely
rather than living with it the Communist
Regime uses strict lockdowns isolation
and mass testing in areas where cases
have been reported the approach is so
strict that entire cities housing
millions of people have been locked down
over just a few covet cases with reports
of Shoppers and workers fleeing stores
and factories to avoid being locked
inside there have also been instances
where citizens struggle to get food
Medical Care and other Essentials as
well as being prevented from leaving
buildings during earthquakes and other
disasters
one particular incident which sparked
this recent surge of unrest was an
apartment fire in arumchi the capital of
the xinjiang region in China's Northwest
10 people died in the fire and many
believe lockdowns prevented people from
escaping and help from arriving but
authorities deny lockdowns were a factor
in the deaths these protests are not the
first against the Chinese government's
coveted strategy but they do represent a
particular challenge for president Xi
Jinping demonstrators have openly
criticized him for the policy and some
have even called for him to step down
but the president has continued to
defend the approach stating China has
not suffered the same death rates as
other countries
the country's official figures have been
questioned for their accuracy but there
have been 5 200 reported kova deaths in
China since the pandemic started with a
population of over 1.4 billion people
this would make it one of the lowest
coveted death rates per capita in the
world at this stage it is unclear how
China moves forward from zero covid
without major difficulties
the country has poor vaccination rates
and the shots available to Chinese
citizens are not as effective as the
MRNA vaccines available in other
countries on top of this in the three
years that China has pursued zero covet
it is not vaccinated its most vulnerable
people nor has it improved the Health
Care system to cope with outbreaks UK
Health analytics firm airfinity predicts
as many as 2.1 million people could die
if the policy is lifted and believes
improving vaccination rates among its
elderly will be key before reopening but
given recent uproar there are signs that
the CCP is reconsidering its strategy on
November 30th Vice Premier Sun Chen Lan
who heads the country's pandemic
response told the National Health
commission they were facing a new
situation as they tackle a virus with
weakening pathogenicity according to
Reuters officials in Guangzhou have
begun to lift lockdowns in parts of the
city just a day after protests that
involve clashes with Riot police another
shift in strategy involves allowing
people with asymptomatic infections and
people who have been in close contact
with infected visuals to quarantine at
home rather than at a government center
officials made no mention of the ongoing
protests against zero covet however it
appears likely they served as a catalyst
for the changes